hallo herzlich willkommen zur israels
ich stehe hier in prien chiemsee mir die
siegessäule
wir sind jetzt heute morgen in berlin
also in der bundeshauptstadt gelandet
und werden für traktor gibt sie auch die
infa gehen die eva ist die größte
industriemesse deutschland und sage dir
alles auf den bereich und alt und
gebrauchte elektronik sein alles was das
technik herz höher schlagen lässt
nicht nur fachbesuchern sondern auch für
endverbraucher das heißt jeder von euch
kann auf diese messe gehen
für mich ist natürlich ganz wichtig der
bereich haushalte sein ich werde mit der
die ganzen neuigkeiten und neuheiten aus
dem bereich haushalt anschauen wie
küchengeräte waschmaschinen
spülmaschinen usw wo rat findet
wahrscheinlich staubsauger und wir schon
mal ganz interessant wenn es denn
irgendwie im technikbereich gibt
bestimmt und da schauen wir jetzt ein
bisschen oben
wir sind jetzt schon seit ein paar
stunden berlin haben uns jetzt hier ein
bisschen was angeschaut und ich nehme
mit verbessern
den stand von de'longhi zu finden aber
muss dazu sagen dass riesige hallen
und ich glaube wir müssen
kulak schrank
bekomme ich die halle 11 gefunden hier
war ich letztes jahr oder falls ja auch
schon
wir stehen jetzt bei siemens teils
longinus dahinter sein was ich hier
übrigens total krass findet
wenn ihren ganzen wissen stände
aufgebaut und für diese messe als alles
was ihr hier seht wird dann in ein paar
tagen oder verschwunden sein
diese stand von ken loach de'longhi
und wie sie zu gehen und mir einfach mal
die küche anschauen und anschauen wie
überhaupt alles am stand steht damit ich
weiß dass ich für morgen alles
vorbereiten kann eine praktische technik
schon dran mit mir schon auf der messe
ganz einfach mal
ich weiß gerade mittelstand hat mir
einfach der nächste mal angeschaut damit
ich weiß was ich für morgen vorbereiten
kann
was die zutaten da sind was noch fehlt
jetzt schaue ich einfach mal so
investieren in die anderen messehallen
rein und nehme ich mit
das ist hier den tischen assistent
eigentlich meine die assistenz denn
das heißt ihr könnt den maike sagen
von salis trotz aller kinder und
interessierte am europacup menschen
braucht kein bildschirm heraus macht ihn
sehr
murat an seiner lieblings reform bei den
staubsaugern
da guckt jetzt mit wasser riss
schwäbische terror am besten machen kann
murat murat
stadtpfarrer hier gibt's nicht nur
küchentechnik und elektronik sondern
eben auch bio tee
hier haben als staubsauger es gibt
wirklich alles damals aber ich hab
keinen stopp
als 50 sehr viel mitnehmen
plätze in der kommune umdrehen und das
ganze
im schönen locken aber ich krieg da auch
nicht hin und da
hier am stand von stores und zwar gibt
es hier richtig tolles erklären lassen
und zwar sind mehrere
herren 1
das heißt jetzt zum beispiel alleine zu
hause bin aber auch mal da kann ich
jetzt hier diesen fakten nehmen da habe
ich ober unterhitze und kann aber auch
grillen
hier unten habe ich damit die familie da
ist es etwas größeres
da kann ich dann auch zum beispiel
reifen machen und auch mehrere sachen
gleichzeitig den backen
hier habe ich jetzt sogar nochmal einen
ofen
und hier bei dem modell habe ich hier
unten oder 91 grad
kuka und ich kann da gerichte ganz
schonend zubereiten und hier oben auf
dem herd habe ich eine grillplatte und
ich habe eben noch ein gasherd und die
ausführungen gibt es einmal in gang
einmal in aktion und das hier ist so ein
bisschen der retro look
die firma aus england wo es passt auch
richtig gut zu seiner englischen küche
fast ein bisschen so
dass er alles offen
platz viele öfen mit drinnen und hier
finden hinter euch die ganze
nun auch noch mal im mutter und wir
haben eben diesen
touchscreen mit der induktionsplatte
da hinten gibt's noch die passenden
kühlschränke dazu und die farben sind
jetzt ebenso beige rot und schwarz und
das passt doch alles wirklich ganz toll
also ich bin richtig cool vor allem kann
auch einfach unseren menü kochen und
alles in den verschiedenen backofen
backen und schon alles rechtzeitig
fertig
und 14
und zwar in nur 5 minuten er machte
die kraft an dem grad der partie pizza
und innerhalb von fünf minuten
vettels register knusprig sehr gerne mal
auf 320 grad um die personen rein und
solange er die andere pizza fertig
vorbereitet
da nicht mehr so wohl auch unter
extremsten twitter seite
probieren
a
zwar kennt
einmal so etwas wie druck
simona quasi eigentlich das studio will
das müssen wir die oscar-nacht sollte
passt damit bei anmelders das problem du
willst
so ein bisschen
zu sehen teilt das fixe ein bisschen
kriegst du
zwei millionen
23 grad und steigen
in der kombination
ok
manche fans stand schön wieder teil hier
abgegangen ist war das ist
und er hat die pizza grad
jetzt auch hier beim schneiden
einmal habe sich gewandelt
sogar wirklich zufrieden
besitzer und gewann auf der messe dass
wir noch ein paar zutaten fehlen und
jetzt habe ich hier nach einem
türkischen supermarkt gesucht wenn ich
kontakt irische zutaten oder bzw ein
paar mediterrane zutaten und jetzt immer
hier bei europa gelandet
und ich finde es karten gibt's im kreis
also hier strahlt so viel los alle sind
gerade der um die uhrzeit ein kurz vor
20 uhr
und wir sind eigentlich hat mit der
stadt ich fühle mich gerade zum bisschen
rechnerin links obst und gemüse und das
ist teilweise selbst wird die aber
teilweise bekommt man möchte ja auch
angeboten bei inneren warum schmeckt
lecker mit junge weihnachten völlig löw
da immer gerne diesen joghurt und den
kriegt man im prinzip überall also den
seitlichen zu vermerkt aber diesen zehn
prozent gibt es in jedem supermarkt in
jedem gut sortierten supermarkt und der
stoff aber ganz besonders cremig und mit
dem mache ich am nächsten tag hatte ich
noch probleme mit der sicherheit dieser
tomaten käse dieser sehr witzige und
leckere und damit mache ich morgen meine
fünf minuten frühstücksbrötchen die
gibt's dann vom türkischen linken super
dass so was brauche ich noch für den
aufstrich brauche ich noch der szene
daneben eine große dose
große dosis hier zwischen 60
also da gibt es verschiedene stufen
murat mir fällt gerade auf ich glaube
wir müssen mal so eine tour machen also
eine türkische firma tour weil ich
glaube es gibt viele zutaten wie viele
zuschauer gar nicht kennen
und dann könnten wir hier das so immer
kommentieren die nämlich 60 prozent weil
der ganz besonders cremig ist und dann
gibt es auch in weniger fitch stufen
also in 45 und 55 denkt etwas fester
auch sehr lecker aber denke ist es zum
beispiel gut wenn man den käse noch
weiter verarbeiten möchte oder auch
einfach nur aufs brot oder zu tomaten
dazu also fällig
hier springt links zu job und da ist es
die gelbe packung und die gibt einmal so
das sind dies bisschen schärfer die ich
ein bisschen das sind die großen was es
kann aber für die großen hunde geht es
denn diese größeren ringe da die
kleineren die kleineren ein bisschen
schärfer
und dann gibt es noch die vorgeschnitten
die nimmt eh murat meisten freude daran
dass auch nicht teurer mediziner teurer
die sind halt so praktisch weg gebracht
und hier ist seine pasta e basta ist am
türkisch er in washington
und da ich außen dieses kämen und wenn
man das mal gegessen hat am riecht man
das noch fünf tage später wenn man
schwitzt man schwitzt diesen gestank aus
aber sich so lecker also man muss das
man stimmt halt aber naja jetzt kommen
die kasse das ist der granatapfel sirup
dann gibt's hier von verschiedenen
marken und zwar süß säuerlich bisschen
eingekocht und den kameras benutzen für
christus zb für bulger senat seinen
kammer normalen salat machen es ganz
viel damit machen das wirklich super
lecker matschie kräftig hat seine
titelstory gegessen ist kommt auch drauf
zum beispiel grad ganz viele suppen
tütensuppen und zum türkischen meinen
lieblings treffen mehr als vektoren das
ist steht sobald ich morgen machen werde
an den linden so für die kann man ja
ganz allein ohne tüte machen und dann
gibt es noch das vorkasse und freistoß
ohne ja man macht sich selber wie so
eine art dauert darüber macht einen tag
aus tomaten paprika mail und es wird
dann irgendwo zehn tage getrocknet
eigentlich an der sonne und dann zu
feinem mehl gemahlen und das kommt dann
eben in die tüte und damit kann man eben
seine super machen und wenn man das
selber macht ist ein bisschen aufwendig
aber man kann sich dieses konzentrat
auch einfach selber herstellen und
lagern man kann es einfrieren zum
beispiel und dann immer so seine eigene
tütensuppe auf vorrat und das noch meine
mama zuvor gerne es ist wirklich total
viele typische suchen dich mal
nachmachen muss und euch die rezepte
gewonnen
hier sind ein paar süßigkeiten und ich
würde sagen dann richtig typisch
türkisches tätigkeit ist dieses hobby es
ist eine art kuchen
aber der kuchen müsst euch vorstand der
staubtrocken und der sonnencreme
dazwischen und wenn man da rein weiß hat
man im prinzip nur staub im mund aber
trotzdem ist irgendwie lecker hat man
muss jetzt eigentlich essen und aufessen
wenn man es mal probiert hat und
irgendwie ist wie eine sucht also
eigentlich mag ich manchmal es dann halt
doch wenn es gibt bei meiner mama den
kauf ist lieber lacht weil damit immer
auf vergessen und hier aber so eine
standardgröße an tomatenmark türkische
haushalte
das ist jetzt einfach fünf kilo pott
sagen da reicht so ungefähr gleichen
monat weil tomatenmark in der türkischen
küche wirklich fast zu allem dazu gehört
wir bereiten ein verteidiger schon vor
für die kochshow später wenn jetzt
gerade wieder so ungefähr wahrscheinlich
kurz vor neun
um 11 30 gb die erste show los aber um
zehn kommen schon die ersten besucher
auf die messe damit die messe eröffnet
und yahoo
das vorbereiten damit die zuschauer auf
drexels zu probieren haben und die
andrea hilft mir dabei ist vorne wird
betreut
und ja wir sind aufgeregt bin natürlich
weil ich nicht weiß wie viele menschen
kommen werden und sage immer wenn du
zehn leute kommen geht mit dem
kaffeetrinken aber meistens dann doch
mehr und jetzt guck ich mir gleich noch
den hut stand an und dann werden wir die
neuheiten hier gezeigt bin gespannt
jetzt brauche ich frische kräuter dem
teig für die fünf minuten
frühstücksbrötchen und mit kräutern
schmeckt die natürliche cannabis legal
wir machen heute zusammen die kochshow
ja und zwar schon wahnsinnig aufregung
ansehen
ihr seid schon möchte ich am vorbereiten
ja wir bereiten im detail gefordert mit
später ein bisschen schneller geht und
nicht um gleich ausprobieren können und
er selbst denn das widget zeigt das ist
ein englisches gebäck gibt es oft
sontheim und die werden mit limette und
mit brombeeren gemacht und im ofen habe
ich schon ein paar frühstücksbrötchen
verbrauchern die bekommen wobei sie die
hatten nämlich aber gut ich sag dir
gleich ich habe kochen ein bisschen
ahnung okay aber nicht so viel deswegen
jetzt mal nicht ein also ich fragen
stellen was zu denken sagt mal hast du
überhaupt mal was gegessen
ok murad von meinem mann so super freute
die fragen die auch meine zuschauer
wahrscheinlich haben ja cool ja und das
ergibt später eine türkische linsensuppe
und baguettes gibt noch schriftlich
frischkäse auf stress herrlich coupon
muss immer ganz kalt gemacht werden
ein bisschen beeilen die perfekte
konsistenz
so ein bisschen krümelig aber wenn man
zusammen trägt dann bleibt da zusammen
er kannte den kühlschrank und ihr zu
diesem bisschen zeit
ok ja da kann ich ja gerne was treibt
die händel rossini ein elektrisch
beträgt am frühen morgen steht hier ist
ganz was gibt's besonderes an dieser
wunderbaren schönen kaffeemaschine was
schon eine
ja ich habe schon eine menge zuschauer
kennen die vielleicht auch die steht bei
mir im hintergrund wer aber ganz lange
nach einer kaffeemaschine gesucht hatten
ersten siebträger das war mir aber exakt
zu umständlich weil ich nicht der typ
bin der morgens um sechs oder sieben mrd
pressen müsst und polieren möchte ich
will einfach was einfach was ein tag
dann haben wir die primadonna lied das
ist auch das gerät was tun und das erste
highlight was wir ich gerne zeigen würde
ist wir können mit dem gerät auch
trinkschokolade zubereiten das ist etwas
was vollautomaten ist ja nicht konnten
verkaufen wenn sie alle aber trieb
schokolade haben mit richtiger
schokolade angenommen also ich hab hier
für eine tasse milch reingemacht seine
ein löffel trinkschokolade pulver gel
da gebe ich jetzt noch vier täfelchen
schokolade tatsächlich sogar möglich
auch ganz für schokoladentafeln zu geben
wenn man sich etwas kleiner als im
prinzip könnt ihr zum beispiel die
ganzen weihnachtsmänner nikoläuse und
auch die untere havel rein machen wenn
er sie übrig und jeder hat so was
wir haben hier die technischen ko laden
funktionen wie betätigen
ein oder zwei tassen wir machen halt
zweimal von der menge schokolade drin
frei in die konsistenz firma sogar
beeinflussen wir machen hohe konsistenz
das heißt wir das länger gerührt und
damit die schokolade zeit hat zum
schnellen
ist das wirklich so konsistent
also wird der dampf eingeleitet der
milch und wenn ich hugh grants einstelle
habe ich am ende weniger flüssigkeit
weniger wasser
okay die wildschweine kommen wenn man
das möchte
das sind dann wird es wie problem
da gibt es auch die möglichkeit sieht
madonna amy von die long been up zu
bedienen und das neue was ich daran
finden ist das display ist da schon groß
aber wenn man so ein tablet hat ist es
nun praktisch wenn man alles einrichten
muss das können wir auch machen braucht
auch jeder zu hause nur den
benutzereinstellungen den minister murat
mich dann darauf tritt muss der
monatsfrist kann man sich alles ändern
dies ganz einstellen möchte kann man zum
beispiel das hergehen wenn nutzer mit 11
gefühlen vereins
oestrich verstehen mitten in der latte
macchiato paket ab gehabe vorne
macchiato glas damit dass auch die
ständig zu hause aus über seinen gästen
präsentiert
einfach so in niedersachsen
anna marie thiemann klein gemacht hat
so schön wie so ein effekt für den
antrieb zu haben natürlich sagen jetzt
kannst du wir signalisieren oder nur
luxemburg ist wahrscheinlich schon
personalisierte auf die tasse abgestimmt
das heißt wenn ihr da im größere tasten
habt kann man da steuern wie viel milch
möchte ich das café entstehen den
geschmack allein schon die tasse tee zu
stellen
den auftrag die milch aufgeschäumt
danach kaum besser
vor allem sieht man dann wie weit der
markt ist auch in der app sie weiter
vorgang ist okay das ist jetzt klasse
die kleine richtung gestellt hat kann
man jederzeit die hand drücken und wir
fordern den sie gerade macht unterbricht
und dann haben wir auch schon fertig
was man jetzt hier noch machen kann es
gibt keine möglichkeit man kann feuer
rein machen oder hinterher
erkennt ein bisschen
als angerichtet
du magst habe ich nicht viel
ich habe ich gleich ein paar andere ist
in der zwischenzeit ist auch um so viel
später fertig geworden
lecker
und danach kann man maritimes von glas
klappern
juli in richtung parlament
aber schon ein bisserl heißt lasst uns
stehen
new zealand viktor kommt später auf
jeden fall noch mal auf die zu mittag
für österreich losgeht mit dem kopf ran
darf ich dir nochmal in europa
vorstellen oliver hat nämlich auch noch
nicht lange hier präsentiert ist ein
wirklich in beleuchtung als man kann
wirklich schön aufgeschlagen haben jetzt
eine einhandbedienung
einfach mal vorne mit
ganz einfach zu lösen und maschine geht
auch mit einem knopf dann für dich guter
sicht
neue elemente das unternehmen ist neue
standard paket für nur 1
und vorne über den reglern vorne ein
ausschalter setzt jennings auch vom
strom getrennt
ok komplett ein
schnell funktionen unterhalb funktion
neue anschlüsse vorne und auch hinten
geblieben
der kleine später noch generiert und
stift es ist toll aus aber ihr habt doch
eine neue studie schüssel ist auch neuer
richtig er hat mit anstand genau das
heißt es ist leichter aus zu diesen
tagen und ich reden skalierung kann also
gar auch noch mal leicht erkennen
deswegen ist super praktisch weil wenn
ich jetzt da irgendwie wasser einfüllen
möchte oder irgendwie auch zwei liter
wasser auffüllen will dann auch direkt
auf zwei sei längst auf der gleichen
seite edelstahl spülmaschinenfest
das was wir haben die partie etwas mit
worden für die 1500 statt 1400 bis 1500
rund 10 jahre garantie auf den motor
weißt du bescheid oliver ganz ganz lang
ich freue mich wirklich sehr
ja es gibt auch ganz viel gerissen ich
habe ich werde gleich eine türkische
linsensuppe machen weil der kleine
frühstücksbrötchen machen dann selbst
bargeld später
dem messer ist jetzt für mich vorbei bis
kurz vor 18 uhr und ich stand heute den
ganzen tag von morgens bis abends im
prinzip in der küche mit meinen
zuschauern hat was gebacken gekocht wenn
zuschauer dürfen probieren und habe
autogramme vergeben und fotos gemacht
und es sind wirklich wieder die
verschiedensten menschen aus allen
teilen deutschlands hergekommen und her
gereist und ich bedanke mich auch bei
allen die da waren und natürlich so ein
messer tag ziemlich anstrengend der
murat wird aber später noch nämlich
später der wird morgen noch für euch auf
die messe gehen und einfach noch ein
paar aufnahmen machen und ganz mit den
kommentieren ich fand sie wirklich super
schön von kenwood stand bei de longhi
und habe auch ganz ohne neuheiten
entdeckt und das ein oder andere werdet
ihr dann auf jeden fall bei mir zu hause
sehen und ich bedanke mich bei euch
allen mitteln noch ganz viel spaß mit
dem was danach kommt also bis dann
o